Úgy mondanám, hogy ne féljünk a
kudarctól, és merjünk kockáztatni. És
azt gondolom, hogy ez is a fejlődésnek
egy része, ez is egy folyamat, hogy
megtanuljuk, hogy a kudarc az nem
szégyen, hanem a kudarc az a legesle, a
legerősebb tanítómester. Bennünk lehet,
hogy van egy olyan, hogyha valami nem
sikerül, akkor azt kudarcként éljük meg,
de vannak olyan kultúrák, ahol a
kudarcokat felhalmozzák a fiatalok éppen
azért, hogy ebből tanulni tudjanak.
Tehát az, hogy én megpróbáltam valamit
és nekem nem jön össze, ez a lehető
legjobb tanulás, amit amit tehettem,
mintsem, hogy ez idő alatt mi mást
csináltam volna. Igaz, lehetett volna
pihenni, lustálkodni természetesen, de
abból se lehet többet tanulni. Maradjunk
ebbe. Úgyhogy meg kell próbálni minél
több dolgot. Nem kell félni a
kudarcoktól, be kell azokat is vállalni,
és a siker előbb-utóbb jönni fog. Ugye
beszéltünk a kitartástól, az alázatos
kitartástól. Aki próbálkozik, annak
előbb-utóbb sikere is lesz.
Sziasztok! Üdvözlök minden kedves nézőt.
Nagyon régóta foglalkoztat a startup
világ, és egyszerre izgalmas és
egyszerre rémítő az, hogy mennyire nehéz
egy startupot elindítani, és hogy
mennyire kevés startup éli túl a kezdeti
befektetési köröket. Lehetőségem nyílt a
mai nap beszélgetni egy nagyon
különleges emberrel, Süket Csabával, aki
rengeteg tapasztalattal rendelkezik, 25
éve már itt van az IT piacon, de a
startupok világában is most már
tekintélyes tapasztalatra tetszert. A
legújabb startupjáról mesél az emotiról,
és hogy hogyan indította ezt el
gyakorlatilag, hogy hogyan működik egy
startup, melyek azok a legfontosabb
tényezők, ami miatt esetleg egy startup
csődbe mehet. És az egyik meglepetésem
nekem az volt, hogy nem a technológia és
nem a pénz az oka, ami miatt a legtöbb
startup csődbe megy. 75%-ába az
eseteknek a sales, marketing, az
ötletvalidálás, vagy a csapatban
rejlősúrlódások azok, amelyek miatt egy
startup csődbe megy. Egy nagyon izgalmas
beszélgetésem volt Csabával. Gyertek,
tartsatok velünk. Üdvözöllek Csaba a
műsorban. Én nagyon izgatottan vártam
ezt a beszélgetést, mert az az igazság,
hogy ennyire tapasztalt
személyt, mint te, akinek már 25 év
tapasztalata van a a az IT világban és
nem mellesleg a startup világban, nagyon
nehéz kapni. És rengeteg kérdésem van
nekem is ezzel kapcsolatban, és az
előadásod során rengeteg kérdésre adtál
már választ, de kicsit belemennék ezekbe
a kérdésekbe.
Mielőtt nekifognál ezeknek a
kérdéseknek, röviden először is
üdvözölök a műsorba. Köszönöm szépen a
meghívást. Én is üdvözlök mindenkit.
>> És kérlek röviden meséld el az elmúlt 25
évedet, ha ezt lehet röviden, egy pár
mondatban dió héban. Igen.
>> Dió héan.
>> Hú, megpróbálom. Tehát kezdjük onnan,
hogy innen a környékről származom, túl a
hegyen, Csíkmadarasról,
Kolozsváron végeztem a az egyetemet, és
hát akkor még lehetőségek
úgy adódtak, hogy ott is maradtam,
és hát azóta
vagyok az IT világában.
mint informatikus kezdtem, akkor egy
informatikus mindent kellett csináljon,
ami számítóképhez
kapcsolódott.
Úgyhogy kellett programot írtunk, ha
kellett
hálózati kábelt fúrtunk, faragtunk,
felfogadtuk a falra, tehát minden
mindennel foglalkoztunk.
Hát
röviden ugye nagy léptekbe fogok akkor
egy kicsit haladni.
a
progr programozói
évek után
foglalkoztam tanácsadással is,
projektmenedzsmenttel is,
architektúrával is, és 2007-ben a a BF
nevű céghez kerültem, akkor építették
vagy szerették volna kiépíteni Romániába
a fejlesztő központjukat, és ennek a
felépítésében vettem részt aktívan
egészen 2015-ig. Amikor eljöttem, akkor
a a
kolozsvári részlegnek voltam a
vezérigazgatója, vagy ügyvezető
igazgatója,
amikor is
úgy döntöttünk két volt kollégával, hogy
alapítunk egy céget közösen,
IT Services céget.
alapítottunk, ennek a neve Zenitek. Ez
2015-ben indultunk és nagyon szépen
fejlődtünk.
2022-ben
600 fős volt a csapat. Volt egy romániai
részlegünk egy magyarországi Budapesten
és Miskolcon, illetve Lituvániába,
és egy kisebb csapat Angliába.
Ekkor úgy döntöttem, hogy még más
dolgokat is szeretnék mellette csinálni.
Úgyhogy visszaléptem a hétköznapi
munkától, maradtam mint igazgatói tanács
tag,
és
más cégeknek az építésébe kezdtem.
Most jelenleg egy
AI kommunikációs
platformnak az építésén dolgozom,
ugyancsak egy közös vállalkozás,
mint Cfounder és a cégnek a CTOja, és
ezzel az új termikkel próbálunk
segítséget nyújtani az embereknek,
világszerte, hogy jobban megérthessék
egymást.
Az előadásodat, amikor elkezdted, akkor
mutattál egy nagyon fontos diagramot,
egy oszlopdiagram volt, mégpedig az
innováció tekintetében, kik a vezetők és
és hogy hol tart most Európa.
Egy kicsit tudnál beszélni erről nekünk,
hogy hogy ez ez hol is tart? Mi a
realitás?
>> Hát nagyon nehéz a a számokkal, mert
különböző különböző kutatások különböző
számokat mutatnak.
Ami viszont
általánosan jellemző, hogy a a startupok
világába a vezető az az Amerikai
Egyesült Államok.
Hát itt több szám van, de legalább
legalább 1007,
ha jól emlékszem 1700 startup
van csak az Egyesült Államokban.
más országok,
amik nagyon elő, tehát nagyon az élen
járnak
India és Kína.
Egyértelmű, hogy ezek az országok a
lakosság számában is
számot tevőek, úgyhogy talán nem
véletlen, hogy a startupok száma is igen
magas.
Európából hát mindenképpen kiemelkedik
az Egyesült Királyság, Nagy-Britannia.
talán talán vezetik is a európai
országok
között a versenyt, de
talán talán nagyon szorosan mögöttük ott
van Németország, Franciaország és még
Olaszországot is lehetne említeni. A
számok nagyságát tekintem, ott viszont
nagyon nagy az eltérés, tehát ott
messzemenőleg a startupok világába az
Egyesült Államok vezet. Ebből is hát a a
nagy része ezeknek a az úgynevezett
szilikon völgyből, szilikonből
származik.
Úgyhogy egyértelmű, hogy a az
innovációnak, legalábbis a digitális
innovációnak nagyon nagy része ott
történik jelenleg. Bizonyos szempontból
engem nem lep meg, hogy Amerika vezet,
meg talán Anglia is ott van a negyedik
helyen, ha jól emlékszem a diagramra. De
Kína meglepett olyan szempontból, hogy
Kínát mindig egy kommunista államnak
gondoljuk, és és azt gondolnám, hogy egy
diktatúra alatt az innováció az nem
jellemző. Ez ezt te minek tudod be, hogy
Kína azért mégis ott van az elején? A
csak pusztán a méretének?
>> Semmiképp sem a méretének. Kína nagyon
nagyon sokat fektetett be a
közoktatásba,
a tanintézményekbe, az egyetemekben.
Nagyon erős egyetemeik vannak ma már
nagyon
sok kínai kapott ösztöndíjat, hogy neves
külföldi egyetemeken végezhesse el a
tanulmányait ezekből az emberekből.
nagyon sok visszament a hazájába, és ma
már egy
egy nagyon egy nagyon nagy réteg, nagyon
jól képzett szakember van Kínában, és
ezt
Kína
tudatosan építette, tehát nagy hangsúlyt
fektetett a az oktatásra a mai napig, és
folytatja, tehát elképesztő, hogy már
nagyon kicsi korba
kezdik ezeket a tehetségeket
nevelni. És hát ennek ennek megvan a
ebből kifolyólag megvan a látszatja. Ma
már Kína nemcsak a a világ termelő
országa, hanem nagyon sok innováció is
történik Kínába. Úgyhogy ez ezzel
számolni kell.
És érdekes mondani India is, tehát ezt
azért Indiára is el lehet mondani. Ugye
ez a két ország a múltban is nagyon nagy
hát nagyon nagy ország volt, és
hozzájárultak az akkori világnak a a
kulturális örökségéhez. Úgy néz ki, hogy
ez a jövőben is így fog történni. A az
innováció tekintetében
és és egy startup életében nagyon
megfogott az egyik diagramod, ahol
gyakorlatilag azt mondtad, hogy 8%-a
csak a sikernek a technológiai is része.
A tehát hogy és az összes többi az az a
csapat, az a vízió, az egyáltalán, hogy
képesek-e vagyunk a sales marketing
eladni, egyáltalán meghallani a piacnak
a visszajelzését.
Engem meglepett, hogy ennyire kevés maga
a technológia egy technológiai startup
esetében.
Egy kicsit ki tudnád bontani ezt a a a
részét, hogy hogy mi az oka ennek, és
hogy mik azok az nagyobb szeletek,
amiket amiket én amik fölött
elsiklottam?
>> Igen. Tehát a diagram, amiről beszélünk,
az a startupoknak a
tehát, hogy hol buknak el a startupok és
mi a fő oka ennek. Tehát ez a ez a
diagram, amiről beszélünk,
és ténylegesen a technológia, mint főok,
hogy egy startup sikeres legyen-e vagy
nem, nem föltétlenül az első helyen van,
de ugyanakkor ki kell emelni, hogy
viszont kulcsfontosságú.
Tehát annak ellenére, hogy
a
az elbukásokba nem a tehát nem a
legfontosabb helyet foglalja el,
teljesen egyértelmű, hogyha a termék nem
létezik, akkor nincs is ahogy nincs is,
ahogy sikerről beszéljünk.
Most vizsgáljuk meg egy kicsit, hogy mik
azok a egyéb tényezők, amik viszont
nagyon erősen tudják befolyásolni a egy
terméknek, egy pláne egy digitális
terméknek a sikerességét, vagy sem. És
hát az egyik legfontosabb az az volt,
hogy egyáltalán szükség van-e arra a
termékre vagy sem.
Tehát nagyon sok startup felköveti azt a
hibát, hogy van egy jó ötlete.
És
hát ez talán talán még validálja is így
baráti körökbe. Megkérdezi, hogy
szerintetek ez mennyire mennyire jó?
Általában nagyon pozitív a visszajelzés.
Pláne ha jó a baráti kör. Igaz, nem
fognak nagyon sok rosszat mondani. És
elindulnak az úton anélkül, hogy
konkrétan megvizsgálnák, hogy
ténylegesen erre a termékre van-e
szükség vagy nincs. És akkor amikor
ahhoz a szakaszhoz érnek, hogy most már
akkor el is kellene adni a terméket, a
piac nagyon hamar beszél hozzánk, nagyon
hamar válaszol, és hogyha nincs vevő rá,
ha nincs érdeklődés, akkor az egész
hiába volt. És már növeltük is a
statisztikán azoknak a startupoknak a
számát, ami ki belebukkott ebből a
problémából kifajal.
>> Itt itt az a kérdésem, hogy ha a piac
egyből nem validálja, két dolgot lehetne
lekövetkeztetni. Az egyik az, hogy a
piacnak nincs szüksége rá, vagy az, hogy
én nem megfelelő embereket értem el, és
nem megfelelően prezentáltam magát a
terméket.
>> Igen. Igen. Ez sokkal komplexebb ennél a
dolognál. Tehát ahhoz, hogy
ahhoz, hogy
a piac tudjon hozzám beszélni, az
egyszer el kell juttassam a terméket a
piacra, vagyis a piachoz. Igaz? Tehát el
a termékem el kell jusson elsősorban a
célközönséghez.
És hogyha a célközönségemnek a reakciója
az, hogy ez minket nem érdekel, vagy itt
itt megint több probléma lehet, és a
grafikonon voltak más
gondok is. Tehát lehet például az, hogy
túl drága a termék,
és akkor azért nem éri meg a
felhasznállaimnak a az adott
befektetést.
De akár az is megtörténhető, hogy
egyáltalán a terméket nem sikerült
eljuttatni a célközönséghez. És akkor
ezek a ugye ezt a marketing problémák
alatt kezeltük. Ez a második helyen
volt.
Azután, hogy a termék nem érdekes a a
felhasználóknak, az az, hogy egyáltalán
eljut-e a termék hozzájuk vagy sem. Itt
nagyon sokan reménykednek abban, hogy
hátha az én termékem majd virális lesz.
Ugye láttunk erre egy pár példát, de hát
ez nagyon kevés,
hogy egy-egy egy-egy terméket a social
média segítségével úgymond
viralizálódott, és akkor nagyon sok
emberhez eljutott nagyon rövid időn
belül. Ez nem egy tudatos tervezés, nem
egy tudatos stratégia része, tehát erre
nem lehet alapozni.
>> De amúgy fenn is maradhat hosszú távon
egy termék, hogyha virálisan tegyük fel,
volai egy nagy robbanás után.
nem képesek ezek a termékek tartani ezt
a szinten. Ugye erről is beszéltünk,
hogy a sikernek
milyen pro és kontra előnyei és
hátrányai vannak, és hogyha hogy a siker
az nem egy cél, hanem a siker az egy
újabb kihívásnak a kezdete, és nagyon
sok esetben ez a könnyen jött nyeremény,
ez ugyanolyan könnyen is megy. Tehát egy
tudatos cég építésben nem érdemes erre
hagyatkozni, hanem nagyon jól
kidolgozott stratégia mentén, nagyon jól
kidolgozott marketing terv mentén kell
meghatározni, hogy hogyan akarok eljutni
a célközönségemhez.
És ugye ahogy az előadásban is
elmondtam, de mindezek előtt már előre
meg kell határoznom, tudnom kell, hogy
ki egyáltalán a célközönség, mert hogy
akarok eljutni hozzájuk, ha nem is
tudom, hogy ki a célközönségem.
Használjuk egy kicsit állat állatorvosi
lónak ezt a a startupot, amin amin éppen
most jelenleg dolgozol az emotin, hogy
kicsit bemutatnád, hogy ez hogyan
történt a te startup, jelenlegi
startupod esetében. Igen. A a az emóti
esetében
mi beazonosítottuk, hogy
hát elsősorban azok az emberek, akik
sokat utaznak külföldre, a kommunikációs
nehézségekbe ütköznek.
De ugyanakkor azt is felmértük, hogy a
ahogy kezdtük ezt egyre egyre jobban
voncolgatni, azt is felmértük, hogy de
hát kommunikációs nehézségekből nem csak
azok ütköznek, akik elutaznak külföldre,
és esetleg nem beszélik a a nyelvet.
hanem azok is, akik
multinacionális cégekbe dolgoznak, azok
is, akik el szeretnének adni a az ők
piacoktól eltérő piacokra, mondjuk más
nyelvi piacokra és a többi, és a többi.
És akkor itt itt egyből felvetődik a
probléma, hogy hogy tudok jól
kommunikálni mondjuk az ügyfelekkel,
viszonteladókkal. Netán beszállítóim
vannak, akik akár más nyelvet beszélnek,
vagy egyáltalán lehet, hogy nem vagyok
én felkészült,
hogy egy nagyon jó
mondjuk mondjuk úgy egy biznis nyelvezet
tudjak közvetíteni a az esetleges
partnereim felé. Így ezzel a mi
applikációnk segítségével. és az AI
segítségével
tudunk segíteni az emberekkel, hogy
sokkal hatékonyabban kommunikálnak. A
azt, amit el akarnak mondani, azt az AI
hát, hogy úgy mondjam, egy kicsit
megszépítse és adaptálja. Talán ez lenne
az ide helyes idegen szó rá
hoz, akivel ezt közölni szeretném. Jelen
esetben
írottan több mint 124 125 nyelvet
nyelven tudunk segíteni,
illetve beszélt formában több mint 70
nyelvet beszél az alkalmazás, és ezt
valós időbe tudja hozni, illetve azt a
segítséget is, hogy ha kell
átfogalmazza, amit mondani akarok, hogy
az úgy landoljon a a partneremnél,
ahogyan annak
ahogyannak hangzania kell.
Úgyhogy ebben az esetben itt a
célközönség az tehát az első számú
célközönségünk az a az utazó közönség
volt. A utána beazonosítottuk ezt a
célközönséget, aki nagyon sokat
kommunikál akár a saját nyelvén vagy
vagy idegenelveken. És beázonosítottunk
még egy harmadik célközönséget, ami
nagyon közel állt a szívünkhöz. Ez pedig
generációkon átívelő kommunikáció. Tehát
ugyanarról a nyelvről, ugyanarról a
nyelvre
>> akár, vagy ugye olyan esetekről is van
tudomásunk ma már, hogy nagyon sok olyan
ország, ahol ahol a fiatalok elmentek
otthonról, az unokák sok esetben már nem
beszélik úgy a a hát a szülőknek, vagy a
nagyszülőknek az anyanyelvét, és
problémák vannak a kommunikációban
nagyszülők és a a az unokák között.
Úgyhogy ezekbe az esetekbe is próbálunk
a családoknak segíteni, hogy
közelebb hozzuk őket, újra összehozzuk
őket, és a és az unokák tudjanak-e jót
beszélgetni a nagyszülőkkel, akár
ugyanazon a nyelven, akár
két különböző nyelven. És van még egy
van még egy szektor,
az ember elkezdi őszintén és és tehát
analizálgatni tényleg, hogy hogy mik a
lehetőségek, akkor csak így jönnek felé
a a lehetőségek. A a másik mondjuk, hogy
az orvosommal beszélek egy egészségügyi
problémáról, aki valljuk be egy
szaknyelvet használ, amiből lehet, hogy
20%-ot értünk, lehet, hogy 50, 60,
80%-ot értünk. Úgyhogy az emóti
segítségével
ezt is meg lehet oldani, hogy amit az
orvosom kommunikál felém, azt égkes
magyar nyelven egy egy az egyszerű nép
nyelvén úgymond tudja mint megérteni,
hogy akkor most itt miről is van szó.
>> Üüm, ami nagyon tetszett így
alapelvszerűen, amit megemlítettél a
prezentációdban, hogy valójában egy
alapgondolat, egy alapötlet. Mi igazából
rengeteg ötletet generálunk nap mint
nap, de onnan lehet felismerni, hogy ez
egy ötlet több mint egy egyszerű ötlet,
hogy valami valós problémára ad
megoldást. Tehát egy fájdalomra ad egy
igazi vágyra, hogy és mert mert az ami
egy fájdalomra ad megoldást, az az
értéket teremt, és valójában ez az, ami
pénzt ér, tehát az emberek az értékes
dolgokra a pénzükkel szavaznak.
Úgyhogy ha valami startup ötletünk van,
akkor ez egy jó kiindulópont, hogyha ha
a fájdalmat keressük, hogy milyen
problémát olt meg.
>> Így van. Tehát ugye a pain gain proof
modellt mutattam be, ahol ennek a az
első eleme a pain, vagyis hogy a
magyarul a fájdalom. Tehát hogyha hogyha
olyan dologra tudok megoldást találni,
ami az embereknek már eléggé fáj. Tehát
itt a fáj alatt ne ne ne föltétlenül
fizikai fájdalmat értsünk, de akár azt
is, ha eléggé megizzaszt, ha elég sok
fejfájást okoz valamit. Ez az első,
amiért a amiért az emberek a
leghajlandóbbak fizetni, hogy ettől a
idézőjelbe fájdalomtól szabaduljanak. És
ugye a második lépés, hogyha meg olyan
valamit tudok előállítani, ami számára
sokkal több hasznot tud generálni, akkor
azért is igencsak hajlandóak
az emberek kiadni pénzt. Na most, hogy
visszatérjünk a az első ponthoz, ami
nagyon jól látod, hogy az ez egy nagyon
lényeges pont, hogy azok a startupok,
amelyek igazán nagyok lettek, azok
általában egy ilyen problémát oldottak
meg.
Itt példaként fel lehetne hozni például
a Revolutot, igaz? aki aki látván, hogy
például, hogyha külföldre utazom
milyen nagy
komissziónokat komissziókat kell
fizessek azért, hogy esetleg
beváltsam a saját pénzemet az adott
államnak a valutájára, vagy a abba az
államba képes legyek kivenni készpénzt
egy bankautomatából,
vagy akár vásárolni tudjak a a
saját bankkártyámmal,
látván ezeket a nehézségeket jöttek egy
megoldással,
ami gyors, olcsó és könnyen kezelhető,
és láthatjuk, hogy ezt a piac milyen
gyorsan
elfogadta, és
hajlandó volt alkalmazkodni hozzá, és
ezért a szolgáltatásért fizetni.
>> Tegyük fel, hogy megvan, hogy az ötlet,
és most már valamennyire érezzük, hogy
ez egy jó ötlet. Mi a következő lépés
ilyenkor?
Hát ahogy ugye ahogy megvan az ötletünk
és
mondjuk, hogy most már
körbejártuk a saját ötletünket és
analizáltuk és ténylegesen úgy érezzük,
hogy megfelel ezeknek a kritériumnak.
A következő lépésünk az, hogy kell
legyen egy kell legyen egy világos cél,
kell legyen egy világos terv, hogy akkor
most mit is akarok ezzel én elérni,
és kit akarok megszólítani,
hogyan akarom megszólítani, időszerűé ez
a probléma. Megint nagyon fontos.
Mondjuk, hogyha a két évvel ezelőtti
futball világbajnokságra akarok most
készíteni egy applikációt, egyértelműen,
hogy azt el lehet már most felejteni.
Tehát nagyon fontos az időzítés, hogy
még mindig aktuális lesz-e, amikor ez a
ez a termék elkészül.
És én mindenkinek
nagyon ajánlom, hogy készítsen egy
komoly üzleti tervet,
hogy legyen nagyon jó elképzelése arról,
hogy körülbelül mi a piac, kik a
versenytársak, mennyive tudom eladni ezt
a terméket, mennyi az előállítási
költsége megint csak, hogyha a
termékemnek a a az ára az kevesebb, mint
az előállítási költség, hát az nem egy
jó. Igaz, az nem egy jó ötlet. Tehát jó
ezeket a dolgokat már előre papíron
elvégezni
és előre egy tervet készíteni, hogy
egyáltalán ez az egész hogy fog kinézni,
hogy fog működni. És erre erre szoktam
mondani ugye a Kevin Olerry, hogy know
your numbers, tehát hogy mindig ismerjed
a számjaidat, és legyél nagyon tisztább
azzal, hogy egyáltalán akarok egy
terméket, van-e ötletem, és ez így fog
kinézni a piacon, ez így fog működni,
ennyiért fogjuk eladni, ennyi vásárlóra
számítunk, ennyi pénzt fogunk tudni
befektetni, ennyi lesz a marketing
költség, satöbbi, satöbbi. Tehát mindig
a második lépés az ötlet után legyen a
tervezés.
>> Megvan a tervünk. Mi a következő lépés?
Hát akkor neki kell fogni dolgozni, és a
és a tervet azt meg kell valósítani.
A
tervet ajánlott úgynevezett iteratív
módon, ugye megint idegen nyelv, tehát
egy ilyen ilyen ciklusokba előállítani.
Ezalatt azt értjük, hogy nem nekifogni
egy óriási, nagyon komplikált, nagyon
komplex terméknek, ami nagyon sok pénzbe
kerül és nagyon sok időben
lefejleszteni,
hanem elkészíteni egy úgynevezett MVP-t,
ez minimum viable productnak a
rövidítése alapul. Ez magyarul azt
jelentené, hogy az a az a minimum a a
termékünkkel kapcsolatosan,
amit már
egész nyugodt lelkiismerettel a piac elé
lehet vinni. És erre már tudunk
visszajelzéseket kapni a piacról, hogy
egyáltalán ez egy jó ötlet vagy nem jó
ötlet.
Ebből tudunk tanulni, és ezeket a
visszajelzéseket, tanulásokat,
ezeket be tudjuk építeni a következő
iterációba. És hogyha képesek vagyunk
nagyon gyorsan végezni ezeket az
iterációkat, és nagyon gyorsan tanulni,
hallgatni a visszajelzésekre tanulni
belőle, akkor nagyon rövid idő alatt a
piac segít nekünk abban, hogy validálni
tudjuk, hogy egyáltalán ez a termék
ténylegesen olyan jó-ér, mint ahogy mi
azt elképzeltük, vagy pedig nem.
Tehát iterálni minél többször. Az egyik
oka, és egyik legnagyobb oka, ami miatt
csődtbe megy egy egy ilyen startup
ötletünk, az az, hogy elfogy a a tőkénk,
amit be tudtunk vonni.
>> A 18% volt, ha jól emlékszem, valami
ilyesmi.
>> Elég Igen, egy elég nagy szet,
>> elég nagy szelet volt belőle. Tehát
gyakorlatilag addig iterálunk, ameddig
vagy túlliteráljuk és és kijutunk és és
el elírjuk azt a pontot, amikor már
valamennyi tőkétbe tudunk még vonni,
vagy elfogy a pénzünk. Hát itt azt látni
kell, hogy ez az iteráció, ez több
szempontból nagyon-nagyon előnyös. Az
egyik a a amit az előbb említettem, hogy
azokat a feltevéseket
tudjuk vele igazolni,
amiket a tervezési szakaszba
megfogalmaztunk. Ez nagyon-nagyon
fontos, mert megtörténhet, hogy ezek a
feltevések igazak vagy hamisak. Ezt csak
akkor tudjuk, hogyha kipróbáljuk. A
puding próbálja az evés. Ezt több több
helyen elmondtam.
A másik nagyon érdekes dolog egy
iteratív megközelítéssel, hogyha nagyon
ügyesen tervezem az iterációimat,
nevezzük őket verzióknak, akkor már az
MVP
lehet, hogy hozhat valamennyi
bejövetelt. Tehát azt jelenti, hogy egy
iteratív szoftverfejlesztési
megközelítéssel
előre tudom hozni, hogy mikor kezd
egyáltalán az én termékem jövedelmet
termelni. Nem három év múlva fog hozni,
hanem nem lehet, hogy már az első vagy a
második te látsz, hanem ezt mindenki el
kell döntse. Lehet, hogy az első MVP-re
nem akarok annyit befektetni,
hogy már
monetizálni is lehessen és pénzt
lehessen értekérni, de már a második,
harmadiknál igen. És ez megint egy olyan
védelmi mechanizmus a befektetés
szempontjából is, hogy ahelyett, hogy
elköltenék három évny fejlesztésnek az
árát, három hónap alatt
esetleg rájövök, hogy ez nem volt a
legjobb ötlet, és leállítom a
befektetést, és azt, amit elégtem volna
a maradék 1,6 évbe, azt azt az összeget
ezzel megmentettem. Tehát rengeteg
rengeteg
segítséget tud nyújtani egy ilyen
hozzááll.
>> Igen. Amit még itt talán itt érzek ebbe,
hogy kicsit olyan, mint amikor vannak
azok a hosszú lufik, amiből lehet
hajtogatni
egy elefántot, és hogyha nagyon gyorsan
tudunk egy elefántot hajtogatni, és
rájövünk arra, hogy három hónap alatt,
hogy nem pont erre van szükség, akkor át
tudom egy egérré alakítani nagyon
gyorsan.
>> Így van. Így van. Hogyha nem az elefánt
kell, hanem esetleg kutyát vennének a
gyerekek, akkor
>> akkor gyorsan hajtogatok. És hogyha nem
gyártottam le már nem tudom hány millió
elefántot, csak egyet, akkor még még
könnyebb ugye ez az átalakítás.
Tegyük fel, hogy most iteráltunk és nem
buktunk el, mert nyilván a a
befektet volt egy másik nagyon érdekes
slajod, mindegyiket lefényképeztem, és
így ahogy miközben beszélgetünk, így
arra is rájöttem, hogy nem fog idő jutni
mindenre, hogy beszéljünk arról, ami
fontos. Úgyhogy ez egy jó teszt is lesz.
Tehát a hallgatók közül kérlek írjátok
meg kommentbe, hogyha szeretnétek, hogy
Csabával leüljünk és két órát rászánjunk
és belemenjünk a részleteibe, akkor
akkor kommenteljetek, adjatok egy
lájkot, osszátok meg a videót, mert ez
is egy visszajelzés nekünk, egy gyors
visszajelzés, hogy értékes-e, elég
értékes-e az, amit amiről kezdtünk
beszélgetni. Szóval visszatérve magáról
a startupról, ez ez engem nagyon
megérintett, hogy hogy egy teljesen más
mentalitásra van szükség ebben a startup
világban, mint amit ahogy például az
egyetemen tanultam, vagy ezbe a
posztkommunista világban, ahol én nőttem
fel, tanultam, ahol megtanultunk egy
szakmát és valamivé váltunk és ki
kellett tartania mellett, ami és és arra
számítottunk, hogy a szakmánk az lesz
ehelyett ebben az a startup világban
nagyon-nagyon gyorsan kell tudjuk az
alakunkat változtatni, gyorsan kell
tudjunk reagálni a piacra.
>> Így van.
>> És
és ami nagyon fontos, Ja, igen. Én és
erről erről mindenképpen kell
beszéljünk, hogy volt egy slajdod,
amikor valaki ásott és egy gyémánt fele
az utolsó ütéssel éppen elérte volna a
kincset, de nem érte el, mert szomorúan
visszafordult.
És az jött fel bennem, hogy a makadság
és a kitartás között, és gyakran nem
tudjuk, mi a különbség, összetévesszük.
ugyanis amiről te beszéltél, az egy éber
alázatos figyelem folyamatosan a piacon,
és egyszerre párosul egy kitartással.
Tehát egyszerre le lehetünk alázatosak
és egyszerre lehetünk kitartóak.
>> Igen. Igen.
>> És ez egy ez egy ez egy fontos dolog,
hogy nem ne keverjük össze a kettőt.
>> Ez ez egy nagyon fontos dolog.
mondhatnám, hogy pláne nekünk
székelyeknek,
hogy nem makacsú ragaszkodni kell az
előző ötlethez,
hanem kitartani ez az iteratív üzemmód
mellett, amit az előbb
elmagyaráztam,
illetve amellett, hogy elkészítem,
igenis kitartok az ötletem elett,
elkészítem az ötletemet, implementálom
az ötletemet, de utána, ahogy te
fogalmaztál és nagyon tetszik,
alázatosan meghallgatom a
visszajelzéseket.
Mert a piac hozzám, a piac jelez. Nagyon
nehéz a piact megváltoztatni, a piaccal
haladni lehet,
rá lehet hangolódni a piacra, de hát a
piacot megváltoztatni óriási pénzekbe
kerülne, és nem is biztos, nem is
garantált, hogy sikerül,
>> de ez annál is inkább nehezebb, hogy
amikor van egy jó ötletünk,
beleszerettünk sokszor az ötletünkbe.
>> Hát ez ez emberi dolog. Igen.
>> Ez ez amúgy nálad hogy van? Gyanítom,
hogy rengeteg ötletet generáltál már
eddig a az évek során.
>> Nehezen válsz meg tőlük?
>> Hát ezt ma már megtanultam, hogy minden
ötlet addig jó, amíg be nem igazolódik,
hogy nem. És akkor azt el kell fogadni
és ide kell a kitartás. Akkor nem akkor
nem el kell csüggedni, hanem meg kell
hallgatni a visszajelzéseket. A
visszajelzéseket be kell építeni az
eredeti ötletünkbe, és elő kell állni
egy sokkal jobb verzióval.
Az az is a mi ötletünk, csak már
beépítettük a piaci visszajelzéseket. A
következő verziónk lehet, hogy már
sokkal jobb, de még mindig fognak jönni
a visszajelzések. És hát ennek sosincs
vége. Itt ugye példának tudnám hozni a
az első verziós iPhone-okat, amik hát
valljuk be nem voltak tökéletesek, de
egy pár iteráció után egyre inkább
tökéletesek lenne lettek, de még ma se
vagyunk 100%-ban megelégedve ezekkel az
eszközökkel. Tehát ez a folyamatot, ezt
a végtelenségig lehet fejleszteni. És
hogyha ezt nagyon nagyon jól csinálom,
akkor ahogy például az Apple csinálja,
ezekkel az iterációkkal együtt növekszik
a bevétele is, és a céget is sikeresen
tudják ezzel párhuzamosan növelni.
Úgyhogy ennek a kitartásnak, én ennek a
kitartó munkának, ennek az mondjuk úgy
alázatos kitartó munkának biza nagyon
szép megtérülése lehet. Itt itt az
merült fel bennem most így kérdésként,
hogy ahogy az évek telnek, úgy az ember
én legalábbis ezt ezt figyeltem meg, és
ezt a visszajelzést kaptam másoktól, így
akik elmondták, hogy sokkal
konzervatívabbá és zártabbakabká válnak
az új gondolatok fele, hogy ez a fajta
alázatos, proaktív nyitottság, amiről
beszélgetünk,
vajon szembegy az idő a az idősödéssel,
a korosodással? Te ez ezt hogyan
tapasztaltad? Az évek során benned
megmaradt ez a nyitottság, és most is
annyira nyitott vagy, mint 10 évvel
ezelőtt, vagy pedig kell harcolj
magaddal?
>> Hát most azért lehet nem ülnék fel a
Ringlis Palá, tehát ilyen szempontból
azt kell, hogy mondjam, hogy ahogy az
idő telik, hogy ez ez amit amit
meséltél, ez ez ténylegesen megtörténik
velünk. Na de gondolkodásunkban ez nem
szabad megtörténjen, mert akkor már
elfásulunk. Igaz, hogyha hogyha nem
tudjuk ezt a flexibilitást, ezt a
rugalmasságot megőrizni, és én azt
gondolom, hogy ezt már igen fiatal
kortól kell az ember saját magába
fejlessze, és ezt tudatosan
fenn is kell tartani. Nem szabad ezt
elengedni, mert a mai világ annyira
változó,
hogy nem nem tehát nem öt évre, nem 10
évre, hanem sokszor még a jövő évet is
nagyon nehéz előre tervezni, hogy vajon
mi fog történni. Én az utolsó, tehát az
utolsó periódosban, az utóbbi években
nagyon erősen a az AI-nak a fejlődését
követtem, és ott ez egy óriási lecke,
hogy hétről hétre sokszor akár másnapra
is megjelennek új dolgok, egyre jobbak
lesznek ezek a rendszerek, egyre
erősebbek, egyre okosabbak, egyre több
mindent tudnak. És ezt mi is
megtapasztaltuk a termékünkbe, hogy azt
a technológiát, amit az MVP-be
beletettük, azt mára már harmadjára
cseréltük ki, mert ez a rövid időszak
alatt már olyan sokat fejlődött
a körülötte lévő AI világ és
ökoszisztéma. Úgyhogy én azt gondolom,
hogy aki ilyen startupokba,
vállalkozásokba gondolkodik, annak
nagyon fontos, hogy ezt a
gondolkodásbeli rugalmasságát
fenntartsa, és ez a tudászon benne
megmaradjon, hogy folytonosan kövesse,
hogy mi történik, mik a legújabb
felfedezések, és ezekhez alkalmazkodni
tudjon. ezt a fajta rugalmasságot magad
magadban szinten tudod tartani, vagy
akár még fejleszteni is tudod. Tehát,
hogy hogy értem ezt az alatt, hogy ahogy
telnek az évek, akkor úgy gondolsz erre,
hogy amilyen rugalmas voltam 10 vagy 20
évvel ezelőtt, azt megpróbálom
fenntartani. Vagy még azt is el tudom
képzelni, hogy egyre nyitottabb és egyre
nyitottabb vagy?
>> Igen, igen, ezt fejleszteni is lehet, de
ez tudatosan kell. Te magadban egy
fejlődést észrevettél, hogy ahogy telnek
az évek, és egyre több projektre látsz
rá, és egyre több helyzetet láttál, úgy
egyre nyitottabbá válsz, és egyre
flexibilisebbé?
>> Hát sokat tanultam a az évek során, és
ebből ebből kifolyólag egyre nyitottabb
vagyok, mert belátom, ahogy és amivel
amennyivel többet tanul az ember,
belátja, hogy mennyivel kevesebbet tud.
És ide megint kell az a az a bizonyos
alázat, amiről a az imént beszéltél,
hogy minél többet tudunk, valójában arra
jövünk rá, hogy milyen keveset tudunk
még.
Úgyhogy azt hiszem, hogy ez az idő ebbe
segített, hogy az ember ezeket a
dolgokat megértse. És ugyanakkor az
idővel jön egy kiegyensúlyozottság is,
hogy nem baj az, hogyha nem tudunk
mindent, de ha nyitottak vagyunk és
készek tanulni, ez bármikor lehet
pótolni, nincs erre időkorlát. Tehát
amikor le mondtad, hogy az elmúlt
években folyamatosan követted nagyon
intenzíven az AI-t, és amikor hetente
vagy két hetente jöttek ki a a az újabb
breaking changeek, azok a változások,
amik teljesen akár az emot is újra újra
kellett, hogy gondoljátok ezáltal. Úgy
úgy, hogy képzelj el, szorongás volt
ilyenkor benned, vagy izgalom izgatottan
nézted? Igen, hát izgalom a jó
értelemben és mind egy pozitív
kihívásnak éltem meg, hogy vow is van és
ilyen is van és ezt is tudnánk, és azt
is tudnánk.
És ez az, amit megint csak tudunk
magunkban fejleszteni. A pozitív
gondolkodást úgy értem, és mit értek az
ezalatt, hogy a változásba megtalálni
azt a pozitívumot, ami akár az én
termékem számára is pluszot tud adni, és
az én felhasználólaim számára is sokkal
többet fogok tudni adni. Tehát mindig
keresni a lehetőséget, és minden új
dologba megtalálni azt, hogy hogyan
tudnám én ezt még jobban hasznosítani,
ezzel még jobbá tenni a termékemet, akár
saját magamat, és még könnyebben
tanuljak, még több mindent el tudjak
olvasni, min még több mindenhez hozzá
tudjak férni.
>> Ebben van egy nagyon fontos alapelv.
Kíváncsi vagyok a véleményedre.
A termékünk sosem egy technológiai
termék. Tehát sosem lehet az a cél, hogy
valamilyen technológiát vigyünk ki a
piacra, hanem mindig egy problémát
akarunk megoldani. Erről beszélgettünk.
És ehhez a technológiaz egy eszköz.
Tehát hogyha ha változik a technológia,
akkor bizonyos szempontból még
örvendhetünk is, hogy kaptam egy jobb
eszközt.
>> Mindenképp. Mindenképp, hogyha
visszamegyünk a az iPhone-os példánkhoz,
hát égés föld igaz az egyes iPhone és a
mostani iPhone-ok. És ez hogy történt?
hogy minden
technológiai fejlődést újra és újra
beépíthethettek az eszközbe. Egyre jobb
kamerák, egyre jobb
chipek, egyre jobb képernyők, egyre jobb
hangszórók, egyre jobb mikrofonok,
satöbbi, satöbbi, satöbbi. hogyha valaki
ellenáll ennek és azt mondja, á az enyém
a legjobb, akkor lesz más valószínű a
versenytársaim közül, aki meg azt
mondja, én meg hajlandó vagyok ezt
beépíteni, és és hajlandó vagyok
elfogadni, hogy nézd, körülöttünk a
világ fejlődik, és azon veszem észre
magamat, hogy már nem az én termékemet
veszik, hanem azért, akiben megvolt a
megkellő alázat és a rugalmasság és az
alkalmazkodó képesség, hogy kövesse a
piacnak a a hangját.
>> Tegyük fel, most van egy fiatal, aki
méltán felteszi magába ezt a kérdést,
hogy annyira gyorsan változik a világ,
és annyira komplexé vált a világunk. Én
ami amire már egy értéket teremtő
valamit tudnék létrehozni, addig
egyrészt már változott a világ, másrészt
pedig annyi versenytársam van, én sosem
fogok tudni versenyezni ezekkel a
cégekkel.
És akkor mián azt gondolja, hogy ez egy
lehetetlen küldetés, én inkább akkor
neki sem fogok. Mit tudnál ennek a
fiatalnak tanácsolni? Hát, hogy ez a
lehető legrosszabb következtetés.
És hát ezt gyorsan el kell felejteni.
És valahol azt is el kell felejteni
szerintem, hogy összehasonlítjuk
magunkat az Egyesült Államokkal, vagy
Angliával vagy akár Németországgal.
És azt is fel kell magunkba tegyük a a
kérdést, hogy most én tényleg a
következő Google-t vagy a következő
Apple-t akarom megalapítani?
jó nagyot álmodni, és senkit nem akarok
róla lebeszélni, de hát emellett még
1000 más lehetőség van. Nem 1000er,
millió más lehetőség van. És itt jön a
bátorítás ezeknek a fiataloknak, hogy a
Google is úgy kezdte, hogy két emberrel,
és volt egy ötletük,
és most ott vannak, ahol vannak. Az
Apple is így kezdte, a Microsoft is így
kezdte, tehát bátran bele kell állni,
vállalni kell a kockázatot.
És fejleszteni kell magunkba ezeket a
képességeket,
hogy rugalmasak legyünk, tudjunk
gondolkodni, figyeljünk a piacra,
figyeljünk a környezetünkre, azt
meghallgatva élesen meghozni a
döntéseinket, beépíteni a
folyamatainkba, és mindig egy-egy kicsit
javítani saját magunkon. Én szerintem ez
a legjobb tanács, amit tudunk adni
nekik, mert nagyon nehéz ma azt mondani,
hogy tanuld ezt vagy tanuld azt.
Teljesen mindegy, csak tanuljatok.
Tanuljatok, fektessetek be saját
magatokba, vegyetek részt a lehető
legtöbb lehetőségen.
Nézzétek, hogy mások hogy csinálják.
Próbáljatok szakmákat ellopni,
megtanulni. Teljesen mindegy, hogy mit.
A lényeg az, hogy minél többet
fejlesszétek magatokat, mert sose
tudjátok, hogy ezekre mikor lesz szükség
és mikor válhat a saját hasznotoknak.
hogy egy kicsit most az ördög vége
legyek még azt azt nem mintogyha el
akarnám bizonytalanítani a fiatalokat,
de
de van okuk félni bizonyos szempontból,
mert felteszik magukbó a kérdést, hogy
van-e értelme bármit még tanulni, amikor
az AI hamarosan, hogyha ha beköszönt a
szuperintelligencia és az AGI, már
mindent jobban fog tudni, mint a
legokosabb ember a világon, vagy az
összes ember a világon kollektívan. És
érdemes-e még küzdeni? Érdemes-e még
tanulni bármit? Most vagyok itt a a az
érettségi környékén, egyáltalán érdemes
egyetemet válasszak magamnak? Mit
mondanál ennek a fiatalnak?
>> Hát először is azt mondanám, hogy
megnyugtatásképpen, hogy bennünk is volt
félelem,
és sose volt könnyű. Sőt, azt
mondhatnám, hogy amikor mi indultunk,
sokkal nehezebb volt, és úgy is
lehetett. Úgyhogy én azt mondom, hogy
így is lehet.
Nem kell az újtól megijedni.
Az új dolgokat meg kell érteni, és meg
kell tanulni velük együtt élni.
És igen, érdemes egyetemre menni, ami én
azt javaslom mindenkinek, hogy ne olyan
egyetemre menjetek, amibe azt látjátok,
hogy az lesz a jövő menő szakmája, hanem
olyan egyetemre menjetek,
ami ahol olyat tanulhattok, ami ami
számotokra kedves, ami nektek kedves.
Hát nincs annál boldogabb ember, aki
egész életében azt csinálhatja, ami neki
tetszik. Én így választottam, még
hatodikos koromban döntöttem, hogy
informatikus szeretnék lenni. Azóta ezen
a pályán vagyok. Én soha meg nem bántam,
hogy ebbe az irányba indultam el. Én
mindenkinek ezt kívánom, hogy ő saját
maga döntse el, mi az, ami neki tetszik.
Abba az irányba induljon el, abba a
dologba legyen jó. És hogyha abba a
dologba jó vagy, biztos, hogy a sikerek
is fognak jönni.
Tehát üljön le egy fiatal és figyelje
meg magát, hogy mi az, ami izgalommal
tölti el a és és kezdjen bele
mindenfélébe. Mindenféle lehetőséget
próbáljon.
>> És ha még ha még nem tudja, akkor ki
kell próbálnia önmagát különböző
helyzetekbe.
Bele kell menni olyan olyan helyzetekbe,
ahol ahol meg tudom próbálni, mire
gondolok. Nem tudom, hogy tetszenek-e a
számítógépek, akkor el kell kezdeni
számítógépekkel foglalkozni. Nem tudom,
hogy tetszik-e a média világa, akkor
lehet, hogy kell csinálni egy kis
YouTube csatornát. Nem tudom, hogy
tetszik-e a rádiózás. Valahogy meg kell
próbálni egy kis rádióadást összehozni.
Tehát a lényeg az, hogy ne üljünk
tétlenül minél több minél több dolgot
próbáljunk ki addig, amíg az egyik
előbb-utóbb csak bejön és csak fog
tetszeni, és akkor azon kell tovább
jönni.
>> Igen. Itt a a bolond archetípusát látom,
hogy mindig a bolondból lesz a megváltó.
Ez egy ilyen jungi archetípus, de minden
megváltó, bocsánat, minden bolond nem
lesz megváltó, de néhány
néhány néhány megváltó előtte kell, hogy
rizikóztassa azt, hogy bolond előtte,
hogy neki kell fogjunk olyan dolgoknak,
amiben rosszul fogjuk csinálni,
bolondnak fogunk tűnni és lehet, hogy
néha azok is leszünk, tehát hogy rosszul
csináljuk és kikacagnak, vagy mi
kacagjuk ki magunkat, ha kellő
önkritikánk van. De hogy
>> nem szabad a én úgy mondanám ezt
szebben, hogy elnézést kérek. Nem
szebben, akkor másképp. Úgy mondanám,
hogy ne féljünk a kudarctól és merjünk
kockáztatni.
És azt gondolom, hogy ez is a
fejlődésnek egy része, ez is egy
folyamat, hogy megtanuljuk, hogy a
kudarc az nem szégyen, hanem a kudarc az
a legesle, a legerősebb tanítómester.
>> Ühüm.
Bennünk lehet, hogy van egy olyan, hogy
hogyha valami nem sikerül, akkor azt
kudarcként éljük meg. De vannak olyan
kultúrák, ahol a kudarcokat felhalmozzák
a fiatalok éppen azért, hogy ebből
tanulni tudjanak. Tehát az, hogy én
megpróbáltam valamit és nekem nem jön
össze, ez a lehető legjobb tanulás, amit
amit tehettem,
mintsem, hogy ez idő alatt mi mást
csináltam volna. Igaz, lehetett volna
pihenni, lustálkodni természetesen, de
abból se lehet többet tanulni. Maradjunk
ebbe. Úgyhogy meg kell próbálni minél
több dolgot, nem kell félni a
kudarcoktól, be kell azokat is vállalni,
és a siker előbb-utóbb jönni fog. Ugye
beszéltünk a kitartástól, az alázatos
kitartástól. Aki próbálkozik, annak
előbb-utóbb sikere is lesz.
>> Hát Csaba, köszönöm szépen ezt a
beszélgetést. És én azt hiszem, hogy
ennél jobb pont, hogy megálljunk és
és lefonjuk a konklúziókat. Most nem is
lehetne. Köszönöm, hogy elvállaltad ezt
a beszélgetést, és tényleg a a a
felét vettük át, vagy a negyedét annak,
amiről szerettem volna beszélgetni. Ez
egy nagyon izgalmas kérdés, mert nem
nagyon vannak mentorok itt
székhelyföldön, akikhez lehet fordulni.
Nem nagyon vannak emberek, akiket meg
tudok kérdezni, és konkrét tapasztalata
van arról, hogyha elindítanak egy
startupot, akkor akkor hogyan menjenek
tovább. És nem is csoda, hogy ekkora a
kudarc utána, mert ameddig egy silicium
völgyben
nagyon nagyon koncentráltan ott vannak
nagyon-nagyon tapasztalt emberek, akik
nagyon-nagyon sok kudarc után, de nagyon
látványos sikerekkel
rengeteg tapasztalattal rendelkeznek. És
lehet, hogy elmegyek kávézni ezzel a
személlyel, vagy akár
egy hónapon belül találkozhatok 5-10
olyan emberrel, aki akinek rengeteg
kapcsolata van. Ez azért nem jellemző
Székelyföldre. És az az igazság, hogy
tényleg ez a Máté elve ez akinek sok
van, annak még több adatik, és akinek
kevés van, attól elvétetik az is. Picit
így ezt érzem, mint Székelyföldön is,
hogy neki kell fogjunk és kell
bátorítsuk magunkat legalábbis és
egymást, hogy hogy merjünk kudarcot
vallani és és az én tapasztalatom plusz
a te tapasztalatod az nem egy plusz
egből lesz kettő, hanem ahogy említetted
te is, ebből lehet öt is, vagy 10 is.
Tehát ez a szinergikus kapcsolat, amikor
a te tapasztalatodat fel tudom
használni, a kapcsolatrendszeredet fel
tudom használni, és és fordítva ez ez
valójában itt akkor azt jelenti, hogy a
bizalom, a kapcsolati tőke, az alázat, a
kitartás valójában sokkal fontosabb,
mint a pénz, sokkal fontosabb, mint a a
a nyers erőforrás egy ország számára.
>> Így van. És ezek azok a dolgok, amit
mindenki tud építeni, és elkezdhet
akármilyen fiatal korban már építeni.
Itt nagyon szépen lehet látni a a nagy
cégeknél, hogy a ezeket a nagy cégeket
nagyon sokszor gyerekkori barátok
alapítják, vagy olyan
ennek egyetemistán egyetemista társak,
vagy iskolatársak, kollégák satöbbi.
Tehát ez ez nagyon így van, hogy nem a
pénz a legnagyobb akadály. És lehet,
hogy ez nagyon sokaknak furcsán fog
hangzani, de én remélem, hogy ugyanakkor
bátorítóként is fog hangzani, hogy nem a
pénz az, ami a legnagyobb akadály. És
hogyha kicsit visszacsatolhatok a
bemutatómhoz, ugye ott nagyon jól láttuk
a grafikonokon, hogy a fő ok a
startupoknak a a
problémái között egyáltalán nem a pénz
volt. Sőt, ugye azt is elmondtuk, hogy a
a
tőkebbefektetések esetében is 75%-os
a startupoknak az elbukása. Tehát
egyértelmű, hogy a sikernek a kulcsa nem
egyedül a pénz. Segít, ha van
természetesen, az nagyon jó. De egy,
hogy nem elég. Kettő, hogy még egy még
nagyon sok olyan fontos dolog van, amit
nagyon szépen összefoglaltál, az imént,
ami hozzá tud minket segíteni a sikerhez
még akkor is, hogyha netán nincs olyan
nagy
befektetősítőkénink.
Ma már egy olyan világba élünk, ahol a
befektetési alapok keresik az olyan
embereket, az olyan startupokat, az
olyan csapatokat, akikbe minden egyéb,
amit leírtál, megvan. És ezeknek a
ezeknek a csapatoknak azt lehet mondani,
hogy aránylag könnyen
adnak
vagy tesznek elérhetővé különböző
befektetési programokat, lehetőségeket
satöbbi. Úgyhogy majd tényleg egy olyan
világot élünk, ahol a pénz nem a
legnagyobb akadály. És én azt hiszem,
hogy akkor itt most már elmondhatjuk azt
is, hogy most már ez már ez nem egy jó
kifogás még itt Székelyföldön se, hogy
nincs elég pénzem, hogy vállalkozzak,
vagy hogy próbálkozzak
valamivel, mert ma már ma már nagyon sok
lehetőség van. Hát ma már akár
otthonról, egy számítógépről lehet egy
ötletet elindítani.
Interneten különböző
lehetőségek vannak. a kis közösségemben
tudok valamit indítani, de nem tudom,
akár régebb volt az ilyen
oktatókönyvekben, hogy már a gyerek a
nyári szünetbe kiment és limonádét
árulta a az utcán sétáló szomszédoknak.
Tehát innen is el lehet indulni.
>> Azt gondolom, hogy ez csak mentalitás
kérdésre
akadályt mindig lehet keresni, a hibát
mindig át lehet másra hárítani, de
ugyaninek ki is lehet fogni. Csaba,
lejárt az időnk. Nagyon köszönöm szépen
az idődet, és remélem, hogy még lesz
alkalmunk leüljünk egy hosszabb podcast
esetében egy kicsit kivesézni még jobban
ezt a témát. Köszönöm szépen.
>> Nagyon szépen köszönöm és állok
rendelkezésedné.
>> Az utóbbi időben nagyon sokat
foglalkoztat a startupok világa, nagyon
sokat foglalkoztat az oktatástéma, és a
következő pár epizódomat erre szeretném
szentelni, meghívni a legjobb
vendégeket, akik meg tudnak szólalni
ezekben a témákban. Ha szeretnél
támogatni ebbe a munkába abban, hogy
ezeket a témákat minél inkább ki tudjam
bontani, és a mögöttük rejlő alapelveket
meg tudjam érteni, és ezt podcast
formájában veletek is megosszam, azzal
tudtok támogatni, ha feliratkoztok erre
a csatornára. Azt vettem észre, hogy
körülbelül 80%-a a nézőknek nincs
feliratkozva a csatornára. Gyertek és
iratkozzatok fel. Ez nagyban segít és
motivál engem is, hogy tovább folytassam
ezt a kutatást, és ezeket az érdekes
témákat hozzátok is elhozzam.